hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well at the very end of part two of his
proma to any future metaphysics Emmanuel
Kant has an appendix to Pure natural
science which is called of the system of
the categories and you know if you know
much about Kant even from sort of
preliminary or summary work you know
that this notion of the categories is
really one of uh the the keystones of
his work but it's not something
radically new at least in its
terminology because Aristotle had a very
famous book called the categories and
and in it Aristotle distinguish 10
different categories this runs uh
throughout his works you see these
coming up in the metaphysics and the
nican ethics and in other places as well
and so this is part of Aristotle's
metaphysics and K thinks that that's
where Aristotle and successors to
Aristotle have actually gone wrong K
thinks that he is for the first time
providing a gen genuine system of the
categories and so he begins this section
by talking about something that I think
we can generalize even further he says
there can be nothing more desirable to a
philosopher than to be able to derive
the scattered multiplicity a
plurality of the
concepts right or the principal G zet
which had occurred to him in rete use
from a principle uh priority and to
unite everything in this way in one
cognition now that's a very long fancy
way of saying what we want to do when
we're actually engaging in metaphysics
or ontology or you know this sort of uh
you know let's call it categorical work
is to take everything and say well we've
got something that connects these
they're not simply
isolated or opposed principles or
concepts they actually all fit together
in some sort of
order and he says that uh he formally
only believed that those things which
remained after a certain abstraction and
seem by comparison to constitute a
particular kind of cognitions were
completely collected but this was just
an act aggregate an aggregate is when
you're taking a bunch of things and kind
of heaping them up together right so
they're not really all that
systematically connected with each other
instead what is happening is you're just
kind of throwing them all in a corner
and saying there you go that's not yet a
system uh for a cun he says now he knows
that just so many neither more nor less
this number ing is very important to him
can constitute this kind of cognition
and perceives the necessity of his
division this constitutes comprehension
fully understanding something only now
has he attained a system so you don't
want an aggregate you want an actual
system and notice the ways that he talks
about this comprehending it you grasping
it as a totality dividing things from
from each other and not dividing them
sort of willy-nilly but along the
reasonable lines coming up with the
right number no more no less saying that
you've actually worked it out fully and
he he's got a really interesting analogy
here that he's going to make to how it
is that we research a language in a
scientific way and and it's good to keep
in mind that by this time not not only
has grammar been around and taught for a
very long time it was part of the you
know trivia in the Middle Ages but there
starting to
formulate laws regularities of
languages themselves and to do
comparative study of language which is
really going to take off much more in
the following Century but it's already
got its Beginnings there so K says to
search in our ordinary knowledge for the
concepts which do not rest on
particular experience and yet occurrent
all knowledge from experience okay
that's what Kant has been working on um
presupposes neither greater reflection
nor deeper Insight than to detect in a
language the rules of the actual use of
words generally and thus to collect
elements for a grammar this is an
activity that was going on at the time
uh people would go to you know uh far
off place es meet with people whose
language they didn't understand start to
learn that language try to figure out
how does this language actually work and
then they would write grammars of it
missionaries for example did that with
Native American tribes that they
encountered so he says in fact both of
these inquiries are very closely related
Now isn't that an interesting idea it's
not just an
analogy he's saying that there's a kind
of connection between linguistic work
and let's call it metaphysical
work so he goes on and he says what's
what's the
similarity even though we're not able to
give a reason why each language has just
this and no other formal Constitution
and still less why exactly so many
neither more nor less of such formal
determinations in general can be found
in it well it's the same with the
categories of the understanding there 's
the amount that you've got and you know
we can't actually provide an ultimate
explanation for why exactly these but we
can say here they are right so Kant goes
on and he says all right what about
Aristotle and he's going to call
Aristotle's work a raps at several
different points and this is actually a
derogatory term in this case right the
rapods are people who are divinely
inspired by the gods to either write
poetry or interpret poetry they don't
really know what they're doing this goes
all the way back to uh Plato's dialogue
the ion K has this in mind he's like
saying you know aerosol is a smart guy
but he really didn't know what he was
doing when he came up with these
categories nor are the people following
him trying to make these categories work
really knowing what they're engaged with
so he says Aristotle collected 10 pure
Elementary Concepts under the name of
categories right and uh here we've got a
slightly different organization than how
it's typically laid out in Aristotle's
book so what are they um well substance
what what it is that you know is the
subject uh not not uh in something else
other things are predicated of it stays
the same over time quantity how much
quality kind right relatives uh Pro T in
relation to place time you can say space
if you want to as well um literally
asking where when position how things
are laid out uh having like you know
wearing a tie action and passion and
then in the the uh footnote here we have
in Latin substania qualitas quantitas
relio AIO posio so action and passion
are being moved in quando ubitus habitus
right uh so so uh when we see him
referring to the seventh and eth and
Ninth what we're talking about there is
Place time and position spatial temporal
uh qualifiers we could say so he says uh
to these which were also called
predicaments he found himself obliged to
add five post predicaments some of which
are uh contained in the former but this
raps so you see that term must be
considered and commended as a mere hint
for future inquirers not as a regularly
worked out idea and so it has been in
the present more advanced state of
philosophy rejected is quite useless
well rejected by some still used by
others and Kant is going to be uh one of
the rejectors because he says it's not
systematic
um and he says after long reflection on
the pure elements of human knowledge I
succeeded in distinguishing with
certainty and in separating the pure
Elementary concepts of sensibility space
and time from those of the understanding
so really important initial division
there that we saw carried out earlier in
the proma thus the seventh eth and Ninth
categories had to be excluded from the
old list the others he said were of no
service to me because there was no
principle on which the understanding
could be fully mapped out and all the
functions determined exhaustively and
with Precision you could ask Aristotle
where did you come up with this list why
these what's the connection here and
Aristotle might say well you know
substance is primary all these other
things these other nine are predicated
of substance and then somebody like H
could come along and go well that's fine
but that doesn't really tell you why
quantity quality relations should be
different from each
other why did you come up with this list
and what about these weird ones like
action and passion seem to be kind of
correlatives or having you know why why
isn't that included under something like
quality right and Aristotle doesn't
really have answers to provide so
this does seem to be a serious criticism
so con says okay how do we proceed then
what's what's my Approach well let's
focus on an act of the understanding a
kind of Acts in general that we can then
abstract about an act of the
understanding fand is HL something that
the understanding does not just a single
action but something that it does over
and over and over over again um well
what is that judging
judgment right the uh connecting things
together in certain ways saying this is
this or this has this quality or this
has this modality or what you know this
this quantity or whatever we're going to
say so he goes on and he says that
um I found this act of the understanding
consists in judging here the labors of
the logicians were ready to at hand
though not entirely free from defects
and with this help I was enabled to
exhibit to put out there uh a complete
table of the pure functions and there he
uses the word uh you know F fun
functions of the understanding what it
is that the understanding does in
engaging in these judgments so he says
these were undetermined in regard to any
object so they can be applied to any of
them and he says I finally referred
these functions of judging to objects in
general or rather to the condition of
determining judgments as objectively
valid so they can be used for empirical
matters singulars particulars but they
can be used across the board for
anything that we can apply them to and
so he says though so there arose the
pure concepts of the understanding
concerning which I could make certain
that these and this exact number only
notice again the insistence on we've got
the right amount of these uh categories
or concepts constitute our whole
cognition of things from Pure
understanding then he says I was
justified in calling them categories the
old name because that's what they're
actually doing and he said I reserved
for myself the liberty of adding under
the title of predicables all the
concepts deducible from them by
combinations whether among themselves or
with the pure form of the appearance
that is space or time or with its matter
uh as soon as a system of transcendental
philosophy should be completed the
construction of which I was engaged in
the critique of pure reason so he's
saying I I already did this in the
critique of pure
reason and now here he says the
essential point in this my system of
categories which distinguishes it from
the old raps City the Aristotelian
category which proceeded without any
principle is this by means of it the
true meaning of the pure concepts of the
understanding and the condition of their
use could be exactly determined they are
themselves nothing but logical functions
and do not constitute the least concept
of an object in itself No Numa no Ding
and Z right but require some sensuous
intuition as a basis so this means as
he's going to say you can only apply
these categories of the understanding to
our
experiential uh engagement with a
spaciotemporal
world right uh in which we we exist and
have perceptions but also apply our
understanding as well so you can't apply
this as others are doing uh as he's
going to say if you think about previous
metaphysics whether aristotles or that
of others they're mixing up two kinds of
Concepts they're mixing up the things
that are
phenomenal and we you know make
judgments of experience by means of
bringing in the peer concepts of the
understanding which we've seen are
derived in this way there there's that
and then there's things that go beyond
that they are transcendental right or
Transcendent and they have to do with as
Kant is going to call it um matters of
pure reason or
reflection um a little bit later on
he'll say that these are foreign
Concepts which might otherwise intrude
among the pure concepts of the
understanding um and he says we can
organize them too we can organize them
into tables but we have to take our cue
from the categories the concepts of the
understanding not just jump into this
other world and we better not mix all
these things up together and say we're
doing metaphysics because if we do we're
being unsystematic and we're going
beyond the bounds of possible experience
and we're going to get ourselves into
all sorts of as he's going to call it
confusion right my systematic division
saves us from confusion he says and he
tells us that the concepts of Reason are
of quite another nature and origin so
they can have a table they can have an
organization they can have a system but
it's going to be as he says uh quite
another form from that of the concepts
of the understanding this so necessary
separation he goes on has never yet been
made in any system of metaphysics where
as a rule these ideas of Reason are all
mixed up with the concepts of the
understanding like children belonging to
one family a confusion is where he
concludes this that was unavoidable in
the absence of a definite system of
categories so K system of categories is
really doing three things one is it's
replacing the totally inadequate
Aristotelian raps of the 10 categories
and you know five other things mixed
into that work ah we're getting rid of
that it's also providing us with the
comprehensive system according to Kant
for the understanding and it's helping
us to draw a neat dividing line between
the categories and concepts of the
understanding and those of a different
faculty that of pure reason which we
don't want to blend in there and thereby
you know get everything confused so
having a system of the categories turns
out to be very very important from K's
perspective
that